he's dominated Comics starred in a movie
brought his way through a video game and
now Scott Pilgrim is becoming an anime
hero here's what you need to know before
watching Scott Pilgrim takes off fans of
either the Edgar Wright movie or the
Brian Lee om Ali Source material won't
be surprised by the plot of Scott
Pilgrim takes off for the official
description from Netflix Scott Pilgrim
meets the girl of his dreams Ramona
Flowers the learns he must defeat her
seven evil exes in order to data then
things get even more complicated how
however while the quest will no doubt be
the Crux of the anime the show will
likely differ from the film's versions
of events significantly in places
according to a variety report Scott
Pilgrim takes off as taking its cues
from The Source material rather than the
2010 live action feature the movie took
some creative Liberties making a number
of changes to the story laid out in the
graphic novels the first volume is
adapted pretty Faithfully in Edgar wri's
fake though things do diverge in places
with some scenes cut out altogether
Scott's crusade to take out Ramona's for
former Flames becomes less true to the
source material the longer the movie
runs though the fact that it didn't
cover everything is hardly surprising
with Eight Episodes the anime series
will have a lot more scope to get into
the nitty-gritty of the graphic novels
and fans can expect to see a far more
faithful adaptation this time around
however don't expect it to be beat for
beat writers has confirmed that the
anime won't be just a straight
adaptation of the original books telling
netlix is to Dum that the show is quote
way more adventurous than that fans of
the film will be delighted to learn that
all the cast members from the film have
agreed to reprise their roles in Scott
Pilgrim takes off Scott Pilgrim Creator
Brian Lee om Ali is clearly thrilled
about the fact that the stars of the
film are back for the anime he told
variety we're getting the band back
together a Stella cast perfectly
assembled by Edgar Wright it was
actually Edgar Wright who reached out
and convinced his former cast to reunite
for the animated Netflix project the
filmmaker said I'm more than happy to
announce that I have helped Co the
entire original cast back to voice their
characters on this epic new adventure
you are in for a treat you totally came
yes I did totally come Scott Pilgrim
Creator Brian Lee om Ali is a showrunner
on Scott Pilgrim takes off and he's
splitting the duties with Ben David
grabinsky the pair co-wrote the series
and the both executive producers on it
speaking to Netflix's tadam Omi made it
sound like a real passion project for
everyone involved he said everyone is
putting their heart and soul into this
thing and we're having the most fun
making it it's hilarious it's emotional
it's visually stunning the action scenes
will blow your mind and there might be a
few surprises along the way this will be
Brian Lee om Al's debut as a producer on
a big series but Ben David grabinsky has
some experience he's an executive
producer on Nickelodeon's Are You Afraid
of the Dark Revival which he also helps
develop and a producer on the 2021
romcom Thriller happily which he wrote
and directed grabinsky also wrote The
Jackie Chan and Johnny Knoxville film
skip trace the least known of Chan's
handful of American buddy com comies
Scott Pilgrim takes off as a big step
forward in his career and he's been
talking to show up in the Press speaking
to Empire magazine grabinsky revealed
that the creators have been making the
most of the fact that the show is
animated taking the action to places
that might not be possible with real
people he te there's an extended fight
sequence in episodes 2 and three that if
this was a live-action movie would cuss
more than Avatar it would be so
unbelievably big and you don't have to
think that way you're not limited Scott
Pilgrim takes off as being made by the
Anime Studio sence saru co-founded by
celebrated anime director and animator
masagi yuasa in 2013 the company has put
out some critically acclaimed shows
since then including Japan sings 2020
and devil man crybaby both of which were
released on Netflix the studio and the
streamer have a fruitful relationship
and S saru seems to be very excited to
work on the show the anime could have
been safer hands according to Brian Lee
om Ali who praised her phenomenal
animation of ssaru in the same variety
interview he said we couldn't ask for a
better team for this adventure we can't
wait for fans and newcomers alike to see
what we and our partners at ssaru have
been cooking up Scott Pilgrim takes off
as directed by arel gangora a relative
newcomer to the position but definitely
no stranger to anime the Barcelona
native studied animation and Fine Arts
at the poly Technic of Valencia he went
into animation and worked with some
studios around Europe before a new
opportunity sent him to Japan he told El
Mundo arriving here was basically by
Destiny I never wanted to work in Japan
because I knew the harsh conditions they
had but my company in France sent me
here with my partner we made contacts
and we stayed one of those contacts was
masaki yuasa someone gongora idolized
for his distinctive art style gongora's
company eventually brought him back to
France but when yuasa founded ssaru and
offered him a job he relocated to Tokyo
he told Al Perry Odo now he is more my
boss than my idol but I still admire him
because he has very good ideas on Gora
won praise for creating the memorable
opening sequence of keepu hands off
isoken after the dances he invented for
the characters inspired a bunch of memes
he went on to helmet installment of the
Star Wars anime Anthology Star Wars
Visions but directing Scott Pilgrim
takes off for S saru is by far his
biggest gig to date returning to the
franchise to provide the music is Anna
manuchi this chip tune band did the
music for the Scot Pilgrim versus the
world video game which is still popular
to this day they toured the soundtrack
as recently as 2022 doing shows in Los
Angeles and San Francisco on the anime
series Anna manuchi will work alongside
composer Joseph trapan a veteran of over
a 100 projects he's famous in the score
world for combining classical and
electronic elements and will no doubt be
an ideal addition to Scott Pilgrim takes
off trapan worked with Daft Punk to
create the Tron legacy score and he has
pled his trade on a number of big
Hollywood movies including Oblivion and
the greatest showman he's also no
stranger to Netflix projects having
composed the music for shadow and Bone
and The Witcher Michael Sarah has been
experiencing something of a Renaissance
in recent years popping up in the Smash
Hit Barbie and turning in acclaimed
performances in the likes of the adults
and Black Mirror the Canadian actor got
his big break playing George Michael
Bluth in the Beloved sitcom Arrested
Development but he didn't become a star
until the end of the NS with a string of
performances and comedies and Indie
favorites super bad Juno Nicon Nora's
Infinite Playlist paper heart and Youth
in Revolt made him the go-to guy for
charmingly geeky roles though the part
that arguably sums up this era of his
career the best is Scott Pilgrim this
info Dum was inevitable 2010 Scott
Pilgrim versus the world is a
quintessential Michael Sarah movie and
Netflix's anime version just wouldn't
have been the same if he wasn't voicing
the Title Character speaking to Rolling
Stone about the animated project Sarah
revealed that he jumped at the chance to
get involved he said it's very cool that
we get to make more of it it's nice that
people still care enough to bring it up
watch it and enjoy it that seems like a
great success I think it's going to be
so funny I've had so much fun recording
it and hearing what other people are
doing I kind of don't fully know what to
expect other than it's going to be
really funny remaking a past project as
an animation will be a first for Sarah
but this isn't his first voice acting
gig one of his first roles was Benjamin
in an of Green Gables the animated
series and more recently he's played
Robin in the Lego Batman movie great
wild Wonder in the boys presents
diabolical and Hank impor a fury the
legend of Hank
one thing that's become abundantly clear
since Scott Pilgrim takes off was
announced is that co-creator Ben David
grabinsky is a genuine Scott Pilgrim
Super Fan he loves the property so much
that he's attended midnight graphic
novel releases in the past he even
crashed a test screening of Edgar wri
Scott Pilgrim versus the world because
he was quote so impatient to see it as
he told the Los Angeles Times he later
attended the official Premiere at
Comic-Con and went on to see the film
more than 10 times in theaters after
hearing all this it probably won't
surprise you to learn that grabinsky
wants the anime to coexist with the film
rather than compete with it in an
interview with Empire magazine the co-
showrunner explained his vision for the
expanding franchise in the same way that
Edgar was so respectful of the books I
wants these all to be in conversation
with each other you can watch the movie
and then go read the books you can read
the books and watch the movie you can
watch our show then play the game then
read the books then watch the movie the
order doesn't really matter they all
kind of feed off each other while the
credit can't single-handedly go to the
actor Michael Sarah did kick off a
reunion that might have led to this very
moment in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly Brian Lee o Ali
revealed that Sarah recently revived an
old email thread with the casting crew
of Scott Pilgrim versus the world it's
time to wake up dude the email thread
was set up for communication around the
promotion and release of the movie back
in 2010 it contained plenty of jokes and
memes but it then went quiet for 9 years
then before the conception of the anime
Sarah randomly replied to the last email
sent as if no time had passed at all
Chris Evans responded promptly and the
whole cast began speaking with one
another again after careers that had all
gone off in their own successful
Direction a few years later when asked
to participate in Scott Pilgrim takes
off every single principal member of the
cast responded with resounding
excitement maybe that's just the power
of email in the original plot of om Al's
Comic when Scott meets Ramona she's a
delivery worker for a company that's
shown to be Amazon Canada this is
Illustrated in a joke that made it into
Scott Pilgrim versus the world when
Scott asks Wallace what the web address
for amazon.ca is that's how Scott
manipulates Ramona into entering his
life but this origin story is getting a
big change in Scott Pilgrim takes off
for the upcoming Netflix anime
adaptation Ramona is no longer a
delivery worker for Amazon instead she
works as a DVD Courier for Netflix got a
job delivering DVDs for Netflix DVDs for
Netflix since the show like the film is
still set Ambiguously in the early 2000s
this change actually makes some sense
though at the very at least it makes
Ramona a Netflix DVD delivery driver in
an era where that was the company's
primary business model Nostalgia and
Netflix both start with n so maybe it
was meant to
[Music]
be